لذلك أفهم أن لديك
موعدًا لتلقي جرعتك الأولى
من لقاح الفيروس التاجي ،
كان ذلك اليوم أو أنه قادم
اليوم ، حسنًا ، كيف تشعر بشعور
رائع وأنا أتطلع إلى ذلك في
الواقع ، لقد تمنيت أه كنت
في وقت سابق قليلاً في السطر ولكن اليوم هو
اليوم وأنا ممتن لذلك
كان هناك أي خوف على
الإطلاق ، لا شيء على الإطلاق ، وأعتقد أنك
تعرف جزءًا من ذلك لأنك تعلم
أنني شاركت بشكل معقد في
فهم العملية وأعتقد أن
جزءًا من ذلك هو أه الرسائل التي
يجب أن تصل
حقًا إلى جميع الأشخاص ليس فقط
مجتمعات الأقليات ولكن الكثير من الناس
أه لديهم بعض الخوف فيما
يتعلق باللقاح بسبب سرعة
تطويره بما في ذلك في الصحة
أطياف الرعاية ،
لذلك نحن بحاجة إلى العمل للحصول على تلك
الرسائل وإخراج تلك
المعلومات فيما يتعلق بما
ينطوي عليه تطوير هذا اللقاح حقًا
ولماذا هو آمن وأن هذا الخوف
حقًا ليس
فقط من بين  عدد السكان أعني أنني سمعت
اليوم من دكتور
ريني المحلل الطبي الذي كان
معي في وقت سابق اليوم والذي قال
إنه كان هناك بعض الخوف حتى
بين المجتمع
الطبي وكيف تعرف أن هذه رسالة صعبة
للغاية يتم
إرسالها إليك عندما  حصلت على بعض
ما تعرفه في الخطوط الأمامية ، لا أعرف
ما هي مواقفهم ولكن في
المجتمع الطبي الذين يقولون
لا ، لست مرتاحًا بعد لماذا تعتقد
أن هذا
صحيح ، لذا أعتقد أن هناك الكثير من
القلق بشأن ما يظهر  لتكون نوعًا من
السرعة التي تم بها تطوير اللقاحات
ولكن عندما ننظر إلى هذا ونفكر في
هذا علميًا فيروس سارس ، تم تقديم
فيروس متلازمة الالتهاب التنفسي الحاد
لأول مرة إلينا في
عام 2003.
هذا الفيروس هو فيروس سارس cov2 أو
الفيروس التاجي
2 المتلازمة التنفسية الحادة الوخيمة الذي سمي بهذا الاسم لأن 70 من التسلسل
مشابه لما نراه في فيروس سارس ،
لذلك كان لدينا 17 عامًا
لفهم هذا الفيروس ، بدأنا
البحث أولاً حول هذا  ن 2003.
في عام 2020 عندما
رأينا أول حالة من مرض covet 19 على شواطئنا ، كان
لدينا بالفعل 17 عامًا من الخبرة
، تم إجراء جميع بيانات ما قبل السريرية ، وتم
الانتهاء من جميع أعمال البدلاء ، وتم تحليل
التسلسل الجيني بالكامل
وحددنا جميع
الأزواج الأساسية البالغ عددها 30000 وهي النقطة
التي
بدأنا عندها تطوير اللقاح
، ولذا أعتقد أن هذا العمل وراء
الكواليس لا يُرى
لمجرد رؤية الفيروس ظهر
وفجأة حصلنا
على لقاح صحيح وأنا  سمعت أنه
من الكثير من الأطباء والعلماء الآخرين
الذين قالوا
لا ، لم نتوصل فقط إلى هذا
اللقاح أو على الأقل مقدمة
اللقاح التي تمر بتجارب بشرية
لم تحدث
هذا العام فقط ، لكن إيصال هذه الرسالة
أمر جميل  حيوي في تغيير
عقول الكثير من الناس